i remember i was born eight years after
independence and india was still trying
to figure out who it was and trying to
figure out the role of women in society
so i think as a society it was very
conservative as it relates to women as
it related to women but in my family the
men in our family basically said we want
the women to dream we want them to so do
whatever they want and my poor mother
who was bound by social norms but still
wanted her kids to soar had one foot on
the brake and one foot in the
accelerator and the combination of my
grandfather father and my mother
were three feet on the brake i mean on
the accelerator and one foot on the
brake and that's why we were allowed to
do whatever we did
what was interesting though was that
when you joined pepsico
the the 15 top jobs were all held by
white american men but i get the
impression that they made you feel quite
welcome at least your face
i think that almost all of corporate
america
you know lack diversity because there
weren't enough diverse people who'd come
in
and risen in companies
they went out of their way to make me
feel welcome starting with the ceo and
every executive they were determined to
make sure that i had the support i had
the developmental opportunities and the
stretch assignments to thrive in pepsico
and i'm you know very grateful to what
they did because you know when you're in
such a senior position in a large
company and you're so different
um
you know it's tough to assimilate but
they made it a point to make sure that
they gave me a helping hand
now you were just the 11th woman to head
up a fortune 500
company in the first woman
of color the media were quite cruel to
you caricaturing you in a sorry even
though you hadn't worn one for many many
years
well you know they sort of pigeonholed
me and said you know i was sorry clad
and
they said that i was walking around bare
feet and singing
you know it was all an over exaggeration
because
i
never was sorry to work except in an
interview i had early in my days when i
left
yale
and uh i kicked off my shoes because the
heels heard after 5 p.m i thought that
was okay and i walked around bare feet
on the carpeted floor
and when you're exhausted at six or
seven in the night and you're still
working i hammed a tune i don't know
where this myth about the sorry clad
barefoot singing ceo suddenly became
larger than life but you know what it
made for good uh stories that's all
right
very very uh
almost obsessed these days with esg
issues but you were quite early on onto
the health and well-being piece at
pepsico and i gather it was because of
something that happened at your
daughter's birthday party
well you know
two things that happened one is when i
looked at the big mega trends that were
going to impact the consumer industry
and food and beverage companies in
particular
i realized that there were multiple
steps we had to take to future-proof the
company and one was the trend towards
health and wellness it was very
important that we transformed the
company to meet the changing consumer
and to change
to meet the changing environmental
requirements of businesses
but more importantly a more immediate
manifestation of that behavior was when
a young kid came to a birthday party and
she was dying to drink pepsi but she
said i've got to call and get permission
from my mother to have pepsi that hit me
because it said
not only is this trend something that's
happening over the next decade it's
actually begun to accelerate now
and for me to make sure that our company
stayed incredibly successful
i had to
future-proof this company by
transforming our portfolio into offering
a range of products that were good for
you better for you and fun for you so
darren started the big transformation of
the portfolio you also saw off the
activist investor nelson peltz not many
people do that
actually you know i saw two activist
investors and i think if you look at
what activist investors have to say
scrutinize their white paper
they actually give you free consulting
so you can if you find something in them
that
will help you run the company better
more power to us because we took a free
advice and did things that were better
for the company on the other hand if
they were trying to do something that
could perturb the company and really
cause it not to be successful in the
future we've got to put a stop to it
when that happens which is what i did
but i did it with respect
and ralph whitworth of relational stayed
a dear friend until his untimely passing
and nelson pels
remained a friend post the
activist
entry and exit from pepsico so i think
there's a way to deal with activists
with great respect and remain you know
good acquaintances with them
looking at the book it's obvious that
you've made a lot of sacrifices over the
years sort of imploring letters from
your daughters telling you to come home
early from work you missed a friend's
funeral on one occasion
are these the sort of things that hold
women back from the c-suite
i should hold men and women back because
i think child rearing is a joint
responsibility
and we've made it too much a female
responsibility as opposed to a family
responsibility and i think that in a
time when women are so smart they're
getting all the top grades they're
hungry they want to work they want to
contribute if the economy is going to
use the talents of everybody in the
economy we're going to have to find a
way for women to also engage in paid
work and contribute to the economy
because they represent an awesome talent
pool somebody once told me talented
women represent the greatest emerging
market opportunity in all our countries
within our countries
so i'm not saying they must i want to
give them the choice to go to work if
they so choose to and given that i think
it's important that
husband and wife both feel the loss of
not doing something with the kids on the
other hand i will say something to you
when you come home in your home all the
time the kids go off to watch tv or work
on their social media
and like wait a minute i thought you
wanted me home where are you oh mom we
just want you around
you know so it's one of those things
where
damned if you do damned if you don't
because
if you're home all the time it's like
mom's bugging us if you're not home it's
like i wish mom was home uh i think
nowadays they're beginning to say mom or
dad i think that's what we need to get
to yeah i completely uh
empathize with that
now one of the things that you're doing
now you're on the board of the
international cricket council do you
feel that uh tv revenues have gone too
much to australia england and india and
uh aren't being fairly distributed to
some of the other countries
well you know um this has been an
age-old problem for a long long time
india is a big big media market because
it's a crooked crazy country uh in a
nice way and uh you know next to
religion cricket is the most important
thing in india
so in a way india is good for cricket
because there's so many people
both within india and in the diaspora
who all want to watch cricket so whether
you like it or not india is going to be
a major force but india has to play
somebody they just can't keep playing
themselves
england and australia are hard currency
countries and so is new zealand
so they end up generating a lot of the
media revenue
all the other countries are very very
important to the icc because the end of
the day we're trying to build the
shoulders of the icc
and we are working hard on the board to
make sure that every one of those other
countries are financially viable and can
build a sport which can give us
15 20 test playing countries so that we
can keep the sport thriving into the
future both for men's cricket and for
women's cricket
in the short term it looks like
god these big countries are controlling
the agenda not the case on the icc board
responsibility is divided to include all
the countries and our goal is to
not just ensure that there's about 20
test playing countries but we also are
in the olympics in 2028 to really
broaden the viewership and the shoulders
of the game that's what we're focused on
right now